hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the clutch chest international
we are continuing with day two of the
coverage Fabiana Caruana versus magnus
carlsen
after day 1 the score is tied two games
were drawn two games were won by magnus
and two games were won by Fabi
now with each winning their clutch games
which are worth double points and now we
are continuing with game 7 the first
game of the second day and it is it is
quite the treat so without further ado
let's check it out Fabi with the white
pieces opens with E for an Magnus of
course goes for his Sicilian defense we
have c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 fabulous for the Rasul emo
attack we have E 5 by Magnus and Fabi
just castles we mentioned this many
times but you cannot win the pawn with
Knight captures an e5 because Queen
before same idea like you would have for
example in the real opus but if any of
you were wondering that's why you you
cannot do it the Queen d4 comes with a
double attack so here are Fabi just
castles and Bishop to b6 it's a bit of a
weird move as it blocks the development
of your d7 pawn however it does have a
purpose which we will see now Fabi
continues with b3 and now the non moves
here are 8 6 and 9 to G to e7 but the
move Magnus plays Knight to f6 is a new
move so already has a move 5 we have a
completely new game and this is at the
point Bobby goes Bishop to g5 of course
now you can paint the night with h6
Bishop to h4 and now a six very
important as now you want to remove the
the the attacker of the knight on c6 so
white will not have the option of going
for this because Magnus wants to bring
this Bishop back to e7 so you do not
want to weaken the e5 phone so first you
have to kick back the Bishop Bishop to
c4 and only now that the e5 pawn is
nicely defended Bishop back to e 7 and
now a blacks position is fine you can
put the D pawn develop and and so on so
far B goes for c3 takes away the squares
from the from the dark knight here also
prepares d4 in the future if it will be
possible
we have castles by Magnus and not Knight
B to D too far we will go for the usual
Knight rook to e1 it will come to f12
III from there maybe to d5 and so on we
have d6 by Magnus and now a for grabbing
more space on the Queen side not
allowing b5 for Magnus and night the h5
now saying I want to trade bishops here
and hopefully get my Knights to this
very nice F 4 outpost Bobbie says in a
way he says you are either capturing
here or if you go Knight to f4 I will
then capture and mess up your pawn
structure so Magnus goes g6 you don't
want to allow the night here to remain
undefended maybe some future discoveries
will be possible it it's always a good
idea to defend this night plus you want
to get your king to g7 maybe rook to h8
and maybe after this Knight moves also
start pushing eh bond so it's a it's a
multi-purpose move so rook to e1 getting
the rook to at the D file a frame D F F
1 square for the knight
we have Knight captures and g3 now by
Magnus eliminating this Bishop H
captures and King to g7 now you've
removed your knife from h5 and now you
can push the H bomb get the rook to h8
and maybe start an attack against fabi's
King so Knight the f-15e continues with
the plan he wants to shift the night
over to e3 and maybe from there to d5 in
the future Magnus continues pushing we
have h5 and now Knight to e3 and already
we have h4 so of course he wants to open
up the position get the rook the H file
start an attack Fabi captures once we
have the shop characters and now he
doesn't want to capture here that just
brings the Queen into the attack and
then you play rotate rate and it will be
very very hard for white to defend so
instead g3 pushing the bishop back we
have the ship back to g5 and now Bobby
just eliminates the bishop right away
it's also possible to go Knight d5 but
the position just gets too crazy for
example rook a trade and now nice the b6
with a double attack here and also you
want to get to the the Queen away Wow
the Queen away from the defense of the
bishop here so captures then captures
and it's just a crazy position now
bf7 point is also hanging you have to
defend it and it's a very hard position
to evaluate however probably of course
doesn't want to go into this it's a
rapid game you don't have all that much
time to calculate so he just eliminates
the bishop we have Queen captures and
now he brings the Queen enter game
connects rooks
they are now Bros for life as we've
learned in the previous video and now
that the queen is on the same file as
the root it's a good good as good as
time as any to open a bf file so f5 we
have it captures an f5 Bishop captures
an f5 we have Knight captures and now
not G captures but rather rook captures
the Jeep on will remain here in front of
the king and of course you want to play
the rook to f8 the double rooks here and
put a lot of pressure on the f2 pawn so
Queen back to g2 and rook a to f8 and
here now your your f dew point is under
attack twice and so you want to defend
it rook to eat you are this is what Fabi
plays and now rook to f3 a very
interesting move by Magnus sort of
saying that you cannot go Bishop to d5
here because it should be five I'm just
gonna grab your pawn here however this
is in fact the best the best Fabi has
for example if Bishop to e4 now you can
always go rook to d2 and you could have
a nice trade here and the Magnus ends
this position being being up upon which
is of course is scary when you're
playing against Magnus however this was
the best the best thing for Fabi to do
like this Bishop to d5 move
however Fabi played rook 81 and this
simply will not do this move blunders
the game and now feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting that you need the free d5
square for the knight and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show of
course it's efore point is you wanna
free the e5 square for the knight like
we mentioned and it's not easy to ignore
this pawn for example if you try
something like rook captures on e4 then
the problem
you have rook captures on f2 you've just
eliminated the defender of the F do pawn
and after this trade yes it does seem
like you have two rooks for the Queen
however d5 just picks up the bishop and
you no longer have have all that much
captures captures and now Knight and
Queen against the road the two rooks you
don't have compensation for the Queen
so after this efore move fob you went
for captures so the characters on e4 but
now the e5 square has been vacated for
for the Dark Knight's own Knight e5 and
now the bishop is under attack that was
the whole point Bishop has to move so
Bishop goes back or rather forward
Bishop to e6 and now Magnus gets the
knight over to d3 which attacks the rook
on e1 and also adds a third attacker to
the pawn on f2 and the problem for Fabia
is you cannot eliminate both threats
with rook f1 it seems like you can but
you really can because now Knight
captures on f2 l removes the defender of
the g3 pawn and once the knight is
captured just rook captures here a picks
up the Queen and it's game over there's
really no good move here like you could
pick up the rook here but then just
captures here let's say King - h1 Queen
g3 threatens mate and yes you will have
a few checks here check here check here
King g5 but there is no continuation for
white here and why just gets checkmated
next so after this night to d3 idea Fabi
played a very interesting move after
Knight to d3 he went for Bishop to f5
and it's it is very interesting for
example now if the bishop is captured
just Queen captures on f3 and after
Knight captures on e1 rook captures here
and you are very happy with white for
example if captures captures white is
still up a pawn and the black no longer
has any threats white would even be
winning here so after this a very good
resource by Fabi Bishop deaf a5 magnet
just goes for the exchange Knight
captures anyone he picks up the rook
rook captures anyone and now rook the d3
he gets the rope out of the way and now
Magnus is up the exchange in in a better
position and now Fabi gives up one of
his pawns to try and trap cross and rook
well not not really trap it but
maybe get it out of commission so he
goes for f4 puts pressure on the Queen
and he goes for this Queen trade Queen
captures and g3 captures captures with
check and now King f2 and now the rook
doesn't really have all that many
squares he only has the d3 square knot
comes King e2 and now you no longer have
any squares you could go g3 but then
Fabi repeats and he sort of gets a draw
by threefold repetition or you are
forced to play c4 which is what Magnus
does but this rook doesn't really have
all that many places to go
however rook the g1 going after the g6
pawn and now rook the f6 the only good
move for Magnus it's it's you play this
or you are no longer better so look at
the g4 by Fabi
now the bishop can move the f4 pawn will
not be under attack but now Magnus finds
d5 of course trying to remove the
defender of the bishop so we have a five
Fabi ignores it and now b6 now Magnus
wants to get the rook into the game this
way we have captures captures now also
threatening the B to point it could be
captured with check and now we have
before
Fabi now hopes that he has consolidated
as now there is no weakness and we do
also if you if you capture up a song
then the rook is undefended and well you
could play a lot of things here Magnus
goes for the most well visually most
most aesthetically pleasing maneuver
which is exactly that which we said that
you shouldn't play so we have C
character son b3 up a song and now the
rook Hanks but it's not a problem since
Magnus created a past b-pawn and he will
push it to become a queen so King
characters on d3 we have b2 and now you
have to choose you either give up the
rook this way Brooke g1 be one Queen
captures captures and you play this
endgame again being down the exchange or
you go for the other line which is sorry
about that rook captures on g6 so you
give up the look this way we have rook
captures and now you cannot recapture
because of be one Queen you have to stop
the pawn so King C - but now real goes
back to b6 and now
you are again down the exchange and it's
not very pleasant so king b1 you have to
block the pawn and now King f6 starting
to bring the King into the game with
Bishop to h7 and now Magnus captures
with the shop character Sonny for and
now a5 starting to push the past pawn
and Bishop the c2 not allowing the post
of the point across a for King to e6 now
Magnus wants to of course bring the king
over here
well probably not in Indo in that way
and grab the c3 pawn so C for not
allowing King d5 but King D 6 it's
really not that big of a deal we have f5
and King to c5 now and now f6 trying to
put the pond all the way and trying to
get the rook away from the defense of
the b2 pawn so rook captures and if six
magnets doesn't mind with King capture
Sun beat you in now King characters in
c4 leaving black with a rook against the
bishop and also a past a pawn so far we
can only wait and see what happens so -
up to age 7 and now rook to f8
we have Bishop the e4 now comes Luke the
EA harassing the bishop a little bit
Bishop g6 and now rook to e7 Bishop to
h5 and only now came to be for preparing
to push the pawn bishop to f3 and now
rook the d7 again you don't want to play
something like this and laundry your
bishop so Bishop to g4 and now rook the
d2 with pushing the King all the way
back with King b1 and now you can't
really threaten mate because Bishop
checks will force the King away so look
the d6 again giving move to white so if
you the best moves from control of the
d1 squared then you can maybe closing
with the king
so King b2 again cutting of the black
king but now just a 4 we Bishop to h5
now a3 with check King to be one and now
rook back to d7 again wasting a move if
King moves then pawn comes forward if
you move the King then you can close in
with the king since the route covers the
this square you will not be able to
check so brush up the g6 now and now
rook the
one with cheque and now the point is if
the king goes after the rook a to just
wins as there's no preventing the pawn
so after this rook to d1 check we have
King to a2 blocking the pawn but now
just a rug D to check King to b1 and now
a two with check King to a-1 and now of
course King a3 threatening rook to d1
checkmate and here Fabi finds a very
interesting maneuver Bishop the c2 now
of course if Magnus captures it's a
stalemate so you don't want to blunder
the game away like this so after Bishop
to see to Magnus played rook the ytube
but now Fabi finds another trick Bishop
to d1
hoping of course for rook to e1 which
again creates stalemate as the King
cannot move anywhere and also the bishop
is pinned so stalemate so Magnus just
played rook to g2 and it was in this
position and move 65 that Fabiano
Kurwenal resigned the game and game 7 of
day 2 goes to Magnus who again takes the
lead in the clutch International finals
so here are you resigned because any
move you make wherever you go with the
bishop doesn't really matter let's say
here just a road back the g1 is
checkmate after of course you block with
the Bishop rook gobbles up the bishop
and this is now checkmate so here is
where Fabi resigned and this very nice
game is as it is so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it we will cover more
games from day 2 as day 2 was also very
eventful and I will have more time
tomorrow I would also like to thank
Jonas Russell Michael Smirnoff and the
Richard Stolley for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
chess international checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day